[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur la grande
interview avec cette semaine jean michel
4 points journaliste économique bonjour
jean michel aulas vous êtes sans doute
peut-être sûrement même l'un des
joailliers qui connaît le mieux le des
structures et industrielle la politique
économique l'évolution sur tous les
rapports de force dans le monde parce
que les marchés les enjeux sont devenus
mondiaux aujourd'hui par rapport à ce
qu'ils étaient il ya encore dix ans le
choc des empires c'était il ya quelques
années quand vous avez publié sa 2014 en
2014 où vous confronte y est bonne la
raison pire économique la chine les
etats unis primus inter pares s et puis
là la chine et l'allemagne
c'était un empire économique et pas un
empire tout coup ça a déjà changé 1
c'est en train de changer l'allemagne
est en train de baisser alors que les
deux autres s'affirme alors dernièrement
vous avez publié avec natasha poly ni un
livre délivrez nous du bilan édition de
l'observatoire pour ressasser sur un
autre chapitre à écrire un peu les
méfaits de la mondialisation
non c'est pas des méfaits de la
mondialisation des effets s'est laissé
les méfaits de du minho rita risme c'est
à dire de toutes ces minorités qui s'il
qui s'érige en inquisiteur
oui mais qui sont aussi le résultat oui
la mondialisation ça vient des états
unis
ça nous vient des états unis ce qui a
permis d'ailleurs à donald trump de
devenir président des wii en réaction
quelque sorte où ça peut venir aussi de
l'angleterre puisqu'on a vu le mouvement
avec le break site on en parlait un
instant on commence par l'actualité et
l'actualité c'est évidemment le corona
virus là aussi c'est un peu un effet de
la mondialisation
oui comment est-ce que comment vous
jugez comment vous évaluez les effets
économiques les effets économiques
commencent à se faire sentir et ils vont
faire sortir notamment en france à cause
des touristes il faut reprendre un peu
l'histoire de ce qui s'est passé avec
les coronavirus quand gym ping est
arrivé au pouvoir en 2012 il avait un
agenda et il avait notamment une formule
en disant il faut recentraliser pour
pouvoir ensuite décentralisée ceni
typiquement chinois
qu'est ce qui voulait dire par là il
voulait dire que le centre pékin devait
reprendre le pouvoir sur des régions qui
étaient devenus trop autonomes et
notamment sur des chefs
du parti dans les régions qui indispose
et la population était corrompu ce très
souvent et donc ils recontre répondait à
un besoin de la population de lutte
contre la corruption
au passage il éliminer quelques
opposants le maire de shanghai enfin
voilà vu des progrès et surtout qu'ils
arrêtent ligue à concurrents et le
centre a repris le pouvoir
effectivement parce que les régions les
régions sont ils étaient autonomes en
chine et très c'est une fédération en
gueule ça et là qu'est ce qu'on constate
est bien c'est que le centre n'a pas
encore totalement repris de pouvoir
puisqu'on amis quand même plus d'un mois
avant que l'information remonte de ou
anne jusqu'à pékin dire que les premiers
cas du coronavirus remonte au mois de
novembre et ce n'est que fin décembre
que le centre pékin a réellement pris
conscience du problème est là agit
effectivement avec toute la puissance de
2,2 du centralisme démocratique que le
virus est apparu là dans cette cité
industrielle
ça représente quand même une
cinquantaine de millions d'habitants à
la sortie ciné aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
qui sont confinés
comment vous jugez la façon dont
justement une fois informé le pouvoir
central de pékin
il a pris les choses en main il a réagi
avec l'efficacité compte peut connaître
qu'on connaît quand le pouvoir central
reprend la main oui c'est à dire dans un
premier temps il n'a fait pas preuve de
non pas de faiblesse mais bath la
différence ils n'étaient pas informés
ils te paye était pas réellement
informées une fois qu'ils ont été
informés d'ailleurs on a vu que li
keqiang jmpit que même son nom sont
montés en ligne il ya quelques lourds
oui hélas ils ont pas qu'ils ont envoyé
l'armée deux hôpitaux co-construire
ankara ordinaire mais c'est ça la
chinoise chinoise sk pas un message là
en direction de trump en lui disant
écoutez en période de difficultés on
sait gérer
alors je sais pas si le message mais
elle est aussi à l'égard de la
population chinoise parce que il ya une
psychose qui s'est installée en chine la
chine c'est un pouvoir autocratique
aucuns diraient totalitaire mais en même
temps les gens circulent au moment de
des fêtes du nouvel an il ya 700
millions de chinois qui se baladent à
l'intérieur de la chine et un extérieur
de la chine et d'ailleurs c'est pas
neutre que
les mesures de confinement étaient des
prises tout de suite parce que ils
allaient voyager à l'intérieur la chine
mais à l'extérieur ils ont d'ailleurs
arrêté
effectivement le les touristes vers
l'extérieur c'est donc il ya aussi autre
chose mais il ya eu quand même des
mesures très autoritaire de président
bien sûr mais pour pouvoir stopper la
contagion il n'y a que des mesures
autoritaires qui peuvent être primé lors
le message à l'adresse des démocraties
et notamment la démocratie américaine
oui on a écouté peut-être que nous on
est capable d'enrayer ce mal
venez pas nous donner des leçons venez
pas nous laisser seuls on sait qu'avec
les droits de l'homme sait que c'est
constant chez les chinois depuis
toujours un
c'est nous avons réussi en 30 ans à nous
développer à un niveau vous ai mis deux
cents ans à le faire alors c'est nous
avons un modèle il a fait ses preuves
venez pas nous donner des leçons bon je
pense que les occidentaux l'ont compris
finalement aujourd'hui ils ont arrêté de
donner son avis en même temps en même
temps on dit aux chinois
n'ayez pas une attitude impérialiste et
venez pas vous nous imposer des normes
qui ne sont pas les nôtres mais effets
économiques principalement sur le
tourisme concernant la france il est à
dire que paris paris surtout avec paris
c'est à dire qu'on va en bas on a
rappelé visite il ya vingt avions par
jour qui arrive à roissy un bon et là
c'est fini
il débarque dans les bus ils vont
directement galeries lafayette et puis
exactement et dans les restaurants et
dans les hôtels etc
donc il ya effectivement une perte qui
qui va être n'importe quel vmh a publié
ses résultats
tout ça c'est sûr la dernière sur
l'année dernière avec des propos très
prudents de lécher loin d'une bande à
bernard montel de qui a dit en fait en
fait presque une évidence il a dit
écoutez si ça dure longtemps
voilà on risque d'en pâtir un peu mais
si c'est pour le problème est de savoir
combien de temps ça va durer
le pic est attendu dans
on dit d'entre 8 et 80 jours parce que
lillois et après si effectivement on
arrive les chinois ont fait quelque
chose quand même ils ont ouvert les
portes de leurs laboratoires
et il ya une coopération mondiale qui
s'est instaurée depuis un mois pour
suivre intras le coronavirus voir les
mutations du colorado minutes et
partager les informations
ddd centre des laboratoires dans le
monde entier là c'est très ouvert
alors là est-ce qu'il ya pas là aussi
une autre leçon c'est que la
mondialisation dont on a dit que pis que
pendre avec tous ses effets pour les
verts sur les catastrophes naturelles
c'est indispensable c'est à disponibles
on n'est pas très bien outillé honni
dans on est bien très bien mais parce
que jusqu'à maintenant les épidémies
elle venait plutôt des pays en voie de
développement l'afrique
oui mais il y avait peu de peu de
voyageurs
les chinois et voyages les chinois ils
voyagent hors des frontières ce sont les
les premiers voyageurs du monde et c'est
ça qui change la nature c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand une épidémie vient
de chine
elle se répand dans le monde entier une
épidémie qui vient de l'inde et allié
hann voyage voyage très peu ça va ça
voyage - est-ce que ça peut pas donner
des idées sur la façon dont il faudra
traiter le réchauffement climatique par
exemple le réchauffement climatique
on ne peut le traiter qu'au niveau
mondial ah oui quand je vois que l'on un
maire poursuit total pour manquement aux
impératifs climatiques
je trouve ça aberrant parce que total
n'est pas le seul à avoir des
responsabilités dans l'exploitation des
hydrocarbures
tous les français et le maire à
commencer par le maire qui utilise une
voiture à l'essence a une responsabilité
bon donc la responsabilité des mondial
pourquoi que vous la risée total 1 et
pas les multinationales américaines et
chinoises cancres et attenberg vous avez
l'air de dire oui
elle invite à davos dit aux chefs
d'entreprise c'est peut-être à vous de
jouer aujourd'hui ces ménages forcément
une autre politique mais dans la
mondialisation de flea les râles mais
bien sûr ils le font déjà redon bon
les obligations vertes etc donc c'est
une logique ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que on n'arrêtera pas
le phénomène des gaz à effet de serre
par un coup de baguette magique et ça
prendra très longtemps et que d'un autre
côté nos sociétés quelles qu'elles
soient ne sont pas prêtes du jour au
lendemain à revenir au char à boeufs à
la lampe à huile
on a besoin d'électricité il a commencé
par les la génération de traite à
combien ils sont là toute la journée
avec la portable 1 les portables ça va
être disposant de la consommation
électrique mondiale
bon on doit bien ça le voir fabriquer
cette électricité exactement bon alors
la fabrication bah ça passera notamment
par le nucléaire n'en déplaise à m
seulement voilà et nous nous avons la
chance en france d'avoir effectivement
des centrales nucléaires il faudrait pas
que nous abandonne alors pour en revenir
justement à la france et à la
confrontation entre les effets de la
mondialisation et la protection
d'intérêts nationaux
c'est quand même assez compliqué à gérer
tout ça
notamment chez nous oui notre pays
colbert et général de gaulle premier
exemple alstom
ça c'est dans l'actualité on avait pensé
pouvoir marier alstom asie mels la
commission européenne s'y opposent
heureusement merci madame vesta guerre
merci c'est ça pour moi c'est ça votre
lecture rapide pour une fois merci parce
que présidente de la commission de boxe
de nouvelles parts non mais là elle
s'occupe de la concurrence rude et
heureusement parce que si massa dé
mettre la main sur alstom
oui bien évidemment bien évidemment
parce que on faisait soi-disant une une
entreprise mixte simplement si mince
avec la majorité du capital est si mince
c'était un seul actionnaire
l'entreprise si mince et enfin ce les
actionnaires français étaient c'est une
poussière d'actionnaires divisé et avec
notamment rennes al'occasion martin
briques qui espérait bien sortir en
dégageant effectivement une plus value
sur sa participation dans ce qui est
assez d'alstom bon
cette opération peut dire d'ailleurs
qu'elle avait peut-être pour but aussi
de permettre à martin ritt de sortir ça
ne s'est pas fait et on se constate que
finalement alstom ferroviaire peut vivre
sol un
obtenu des contrats est quand même très
bon état finances est en bon état
financier et que finalement c'est eux
qui vont racheter 100 sans doute face
est en négociation le canadien
bombardier pour ses activités en europe
bon c'est un bel exemple pour montrer
que rien n'est jamais perdu dans
l'industrie moi j'ai un autre exemple on
met ça veut dire quand même que la
logique de marché a été plus efficace ou
semble plus efficace plus cohérente que
la logique politique ou administrative
mais bien des logiques de mode l'état il
est là pour prévoir à long terme va et
permettre effectivement de ne pas
abandonner et éventuellement des
secteurs qui à long terme peuvent se
révéler rentable des dents profit les
investissements nécessaires pour un
exemple ces chantiers de l'atlantique 1
en 2006 des chantiers de l'atlantique
appartenaient à alcatel alsthom héritage
de la cge et c'est patrick kron patron
d'alstom à l'époque décide estime qu'il
n'y a pas d'avenir pour les navires de
croisière il le vend ils font des
chantiers de l'atlantique aux norvégiens
bon ensuite et norvégiens les norvégiens
vont essayer de piquer la technologie
des chantiers de l'atlantique
heureusement les équipes des chantiers
de l'atlantique feront bloc et ne
permettront pas sur le dock technologies
finalement les norvégiens se lasse et
vendent aux coréens une chance li coréen
stx ne s'intéressaient pas tellement aux
chantiers de l'atlantique qui était loin
et ont laissé le management des
chantiers de l'atlantique pour suivre sa
voie et gérer l'entreprise en toute
autonomie
merci aux coréens je veux dire ensuite
laisser comme ça que le marché de la
croisière a permis aux chantiers de
l'atlantique de revivre ces c'est
important la nationalité d'une
entreprise oui oui parce que là vous
venez nous d'écrire une histoire
hallucinante ou à une entreprise
d'origine une adn française est passé
dans les mains des norvégiens des
coréens et mais ils ont préservé
ils ont réussi à préserver effectivement
la capacité technologique
parce que il ya eu les compétences sont
restés dans les chantiers de
l'atlantique qu'est-ce qui fait la
nationalité d'une entreprise c'est la
compétence la compétence et une
une vision sur l'avenir c'est pas le
contrôle du capital si si si si aussi
aussi parce qu'une fois que le capital
est contrôlé le conseil d'administration
prend des décisions c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec alstom general electric 1
quand vous perdez le contrôle du capital
quand vous ne jouez pas votre rôle au
sein du conseil d'administration et ça
c'est une critique directe de l'état
français l'état français n'a pas joué
son rôle d'actionnaire et de défenseurs
de l'intérêt collectif dans un certain
nombre d'entreprises depuis un quart de
siècle
alors je vous arrête jean-michel quatre
points on va s'arrêter quelques secondes
on revient sur ce sujet là notamment
avec une autre affaire qui défraie la
chronique aujourd'hui c'est la sphère
renault a tout de suite
[Musique]
retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec jean michel quatrepoint
on parlait à l'instant des difficultés
de définir ou de protéger une politique
industrielle nationale confrontée aux
enjeux de la concurrence mondiale vous
donniez l'exemple des chantiers de
l'atlantique qui sont finalement le
produit d'une succession d'erreurs
exactement et quand quand stx qui était
en faillite encore rester le seul actif
rentable de et ax étaient les chantiers
de l'atlantique et le résultat c'est que
à la barre du tribunal de commerce de
séoul
c'est fincantieri qui a présenté la
seule seule offre nous sommes en 2016
pourquoi n'y at il pas eu une offre
française bat y en avait une semble-t-il
mais le repreneur un armateur n'avait
pas l'heur de plaire au pouvoir
politique de l'époque donc il a été par
le pouvoir politique
oui il en a laissé fincantieri acheté
pour 50 millions d'euros
la barre du tribunal chantiers de
l'atlantique
ensuite il ya eu débat de fer avec le
gouvernement français macron arrive il
était pas trop favorable à ça finalement
on en est là c'est que fincantieri a va
doit prendre 50% + 1 % donc avoir le
contrôle des chantiers de l'atlantique
les équipes des chantiers de
l'atlantique sont contre le management
est contre parce qu'il a très peur qu
effectivement fincantieri privilégie les
accords qu'il a par ailleurs avec les
chinois les chantiers navals chinois
pompe la technologie tft rhône s'il
exactement bon fait en fait celui qui a
le pouvoir si tu es quelque à la
compétence call expertise
l'expérimentation et l'argent et
l'argent et l'argent
autre exemple autre dossier renault
qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur renault
pour qu'on en arrive aujourd'hui à une
situation aussi bancal aussi fragile
aussi scabreux nous en fait
alors là aussi la responsabilité de
l'état actionnaire est important alors
on rappelle que bon carlos ghosn a été
et les aventures qu'on connaît au japon
arrêté puis évadés on rappelle aussi que
le nouveau directeur général va être
nommé où il est nommé officiellement à
la tête en italien italie la redresser
magnifiquement d'ailleurs c'est dans la
filiale de volkswagen en espagne à
l'espagnol mais qui a devant lui des
enjeux
considérable la photo les rapports avec
nissan rapport avec nissan stratégie de
marque stratégie d'actes mari âgé et
renault à son cours de bourse s'est
effondré
les équipes sont démoralisés que c'est
renault
il est à à combien 15% du capital et des
droits de vote supplémentaires
oui donc je veux pouvoir l'état a le
pouvoir de l'état a le pouvoir
l'état est l'actionnaire dominant depuis
toujours d'ailleurs
vironneau l'état n'a pas joué son rôle
alors macron quand il était ministre de
l'économie
effectivement ne s'est pas entendu avec
carlos ghosn il trouvait que les
salaires de carlos ghosn s'était trop
important et peut-être pas tort que
l'autre était aimé peut-être un peu trop
l'argent et donc il ya eu un deal je
vous que je vous redonne mais vous
mettez de l'ordre dans les rapports avec
nissan car déjà nissan avait des
velléités de de s'extraire de la fluence
de renault oubliant que renault avait
sauvé nissan et carlos ghosn a fait le
fait le job
c'est à dire qu'il a il voulut
effectivement et le lien renforcé le
poids de la partie française sur nissan
ce que les japonais n'ont pas supporté
d'où l'opération car c'est bien un
complot qui c'est qui a été menée contre
quant aux clauses et là dessus la france
a lâché casque on l'a lâché or on à
renault nissan d'à côté et de l'autre
côté on aps
et finalement qu'est-ce qui se passe
renault nissan continue de voguer de son
côté avec les problèmes qui va y avoir
avec nissan de toute façon et ps a fait
une alliance avec fc à fiat chrysler etc
je suis pas convaincu qu'à terme les
intérêts français dans psa fcf fia soit
préservé pourquoi parce qu'il ya un
actionnaire qui s'appelle agnelli elkann
qui applique y aura plus de pouvoir que
l'actionnaire ce qui reste de l'état 6%
et de la famille peugeot 6% également
pourquoi n'at-on pas envisager de
rapprochement
renault psa l'état étaient présents
capital des deux entreprises
c'est un jeu de monopoly
c'est au sein de l'administration sa
williams et veille il ya des idées à des
contrats sur des bâtiments chez les
dames et sont complémentaires sont
complémentaires
parce que renault a porté à porter à psa
est ca ce qui lui manquait à travers
nissan
c'est à dire l'implantation des scènes
d'un chemin l'accès au marché américain
carlos tavares connaissait
remarquablement renoue à et renault a
besoin de quelqu'un qu'il reprenne en
main discutable le mans et je pense que
tavares était mieux désigné que
l'italien qu'on a choisi il connaissait
remarquablement des deux entreprises
bon et là on avait un patron on avait
des complémentarités psa renault et
nissan 1 est effectivement un état
actionnaire et la famille peugeot
actionnaire et disan actionnaires par
ailleurs si vichy également donc il
vient ça on n'a même pas essayé de
réfléchir à ça ce qui manque c'est que
l'état n'est pas là pour faire du
monopoly l'état est là pour donner des
visions à long terme
et quand il est actionnaire de se
comporter comme actionnaire de long
terme qu'elle est aujourd'hui
pour vous la vision de l'état français
en matière de politique industrielle
alors il a une vision à la fois de
start-up heures ben ensuite de
développer sur des territoires la vie
souscrits tout ce qui est fait n'est pas
mauvais c'est à dire qu'il ya des des
territoires qui effectivement développe
des mets des zones de
réindustrialisation mais il manque au
sommet à une structure qui pilote ça il
n'y a plus de ministre de l'industrie il
n'y a plus de ministère de l'énergie
or je pense que si on voulait avoir une
vraie politique industrielle et une
vraie politique de transition
énergétique
on devrait reconstituer un ministère de
l'industrie et de la transition
énergétique qui ne soit pas dépendante
de bercy quelques n'y a pas de ministère
l'industrie mais est ce que c'est encore
d'actualité mais l'europe mais est en
train d'user mais tous les pays se
préoccupe de rien de réindustralisation
commencer par les américains mais à
commencer par les anglais qui vont s'en
préoccuper tout le monde se préoccupe
c'est par la réindustrialisation sur les
filières du passé sur l'industrie de
papa non c'est la réindustrialisation
moderne robotisés
numériser et c'est la gestion du taux de
change aurait presque plus d'efficacité
pour faciliter l'arrêt l'europe c'est à
deux niveaux il ya ce qu'on fait au
niveau national et il y à l'échelon
européen rappelait choix européen
le plan de transition énergétique les
1000 milliards d'euros que l'on veut
d'investir effectivement que ce soit
l'europe au niveau européen qu'il ne
fasse à condition que nous français nous
nous récupérions quand même une main de
suffisance qu'est ce que vous diriez
comme certains je pense arnaud
montebourg par exemple qu'on a un devoir
de protectionnisme non mais le
protectionnisme
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'est ce que
ça veut dire de protectionnisme à
pratiquer jany ça veut dire on fabrique
chez soi on a un ça va
on a nous sommes les produits feront
vers le protectionnisme ça donne quand
même un peu nous n'avons ce qui fait
quand même quelques points d'avancé ils
voulaient nous n'avons plus nous n'avons
plus l'outil des droits de douane c'est
l'europe qui les a mais oui c'est comme
ça bon donc
le protectionnisme c'est effectivement
avoir certaines préférences au niveau
des achats
c'est à dire que chacun d'entre nous
effectivement on préfère acheter du made
in france que du made in china
ben non le cela dit on va pas tout faire
est pas ça commence à la thèse de
l'hypermarché on voit quand même le prix
oui on voit quand même le prix mais il
faut savoir que le consommateur est
aussi un producteur et que nous nous nos
achats sont nos emplois
l'europe a raté là ça oui oui mais parce
que l'europe s'est ouverte à tous les
vents
alors il commence à comprendre commence
à comprendre avec retard et
effectivement il ya dans les domaines
notamment technologiques du numérique a
besoin que l'europe existe et là on
arrive sur les problèmes de technologies
de télécommunication et c'est tout le
débat avec huawei est ce que la
tentation du protectionnisme à la trump
la tentation à la boris johnson qu'a
tenu des discours protectionniste celles
ayant fait élire oui sur mes discours de
provisionnement il parle pas de droits
de douanes impôts le mans pour l'instant
in il ne passe pas aux as non et est-ce
que trump va aller jusqu'à fermer ses
frontières
d'une certaine façon non mais non il
fait machine arrière mais trump s'est
il est illisible c'est à dire qu'il fait
de son imprévisibilité sa force mais il
utilise les droits de douane il a
parfaitement compris par exemple que le
noyau faible de l'europe c'est
l'allemagne
1 l'allemagne et son industrie
automobile et ça il l'a parfaitement
donc si j'appuie la voilà je fais mal là
je fais maths
les allemands sont les allemands ont
ayant une grande influence en europe
eh bien oui mais peut-être que les
européens et les français vont
comprendre que les intérêts de berlin ne
sont pas forcément ceux de l'europe
comment se défendre d'une pratique
américaine qui vise à à et externaliser
les règlements et moi en étant smart en
étant smart
comment commence dans défendre ces
derniers temps malin c'est à dire que
trump
il arrive avec ses grosses demande à ce
qu'on applique les démolir sinon amendes
ont fait du gijou dessus on fait du jus
dessus mais on ne commence pas
effectivement la taille des haies femmes
vous commencez à dire on est une taxe
diaphane et après en recul je pense
qu'il eût mieux valu faire l' inverse
attendre et puis par la bande sans faire
de rodomontades le problème c'est que
nous sommes en phase d'essai société de
communication et les politiques font de
la communication jour et nuit donc il
faut montrer ses muscles bien moi je
vais faire une taxe gafsa d'aller voir
les messages
et puis derrière effectivement l'autre
oreille mehdi ben moi je vais vous taxer
et là je vais vraiment vous ennuyer
enfin en attendant j mais il dit il
énonce à 52,9 en parler il a empêché ils
empêchent les ennuis cette phase est
d'aller travailler en iran il empêchera
ne l'ont pas en parler mais le faire
c'est à dire par la bande et à moyens de
gêner par exemple les américains les
normes sont un moyen 1
et puis aussi ça veut dire aussi
récupérer et là on revient au thème eu
pour d'études récupérer certaines
activités essentielles alors je pense
composants électroniques aux industries
de défense où nous deux nous devons plus
dépendre des normes itar c'est à dire
que les américains puissent nous
empêcher d'acheter certains de leurs
composants cela dispense sur ce point là
le débat aujourd'hui il est concentré
sur why
huawei comme on dit c'est à dire un
fabricant chinois qui al'expertise de la
5g
oui absolument indispensable pour
développer la connectivité dont on se
demande si ça ne serait pas le moyen
pour les chinois de venir espionner
l'ensemble des systèmes économiques
occidentaux vrai ou faux c'est ce que
disent et ce que disent les américains
je pense qu'il ya une petite partie de
vrai et que tout le reste est un
prétexte
le prétexte c'est que les américains
sont fait doubler sur la scène j'ai nous
sommes en retard
tout le monde est en ruine et surtout
les américains autant autant les
américains ont pris position et une
situation de quasi monopole mondial
à part la chine et à part un peu la
russie sur tout ce qui est internet à
l'égard femmes ont leur monopole
bon mais sur les télécoms ils ont laissé
ou hawaï se développer moi j'ai visité
le centre de hachad ya trois ans déjà il
montrait la scène j'ai toutes les
applications c'était en place de la même
façon ils ont pris des chinois en
investissant massivement par les écrans
et du social il s'appelle bo tous les
écrans sont aujourd'hui notamment les
écrans qui vont être pliée en laisse
parfois ce sont eux qui ont les brevets
avec samsung se sont re dans sait
combien ils ont investi sur les écrans
depuis 20 ans ce sont des terrains 50
milliards de dollars 50 milliards de
dollars
bien sûr les écrans brillants quoi il
arrive aux ondes
ils sont les leaders mondiaux bon nous
nous avons pris du retard
les américains ont pris du retard sur la
femme jane les anglais viennent de huy
d'autoriser oui a alors si vous êtes à
la condition il me montre bien ce qu'on
peut faire
mais contre l'avis des américains car
américain cela dit wouah il ne pourra
pas s'installer installé ses équipements
à côté des centres mais des bases
militaires
en plus ils vont limiter à 35 % du
marché hawaï c'est c'est ce que va faire
l'europe se prépare à envoyer des as et
la question je vais voter comme je pense
que pour l'instant elle est pas l est
pas opposée à war et orange par exemple
aveu vient de viens de dire on prendra
vie parce que d'abord wild a vendu
depuis depuis dix ans ses propres
équipements sur la 4g donc déjà les
systèmes des opérateurs
sont en partie dépendant de huawei pour
leurs équipements ils peuvent pas se
passer du jour au lendemain une lettre
de comptes compatibilité donc ce qui va
se passer c'est qu'on va mettre des
conditions
effectivement pour préserver pour se
prémunir de risques éventuels
d'espionnage ne pas laisser tout le
marché hawaï favorisé la montée en
puissance de nokia et d'ericsson à et
partager le marché ça la vraie raison en
fait c'est le 10 août et la concurrence
est bien sûr un bien sûr bien sûr et
c'est vrai que les américains
effectivement n'ont pas supporté que
huawei des doubles mais c'est leur faute
ils avaient quatre cas travailler sur la
salle g jean-michel 80
on pourrait continuer ce décryptage
encore très longtemps parce que c'est
passionnant
on se retrouvera un sur sur ces grands
dossiers on retrouve cette émission en
rediffusion bien sûr sur la chaîne en
replay on la retrouve sur les réseaux
sociaux cela dans le monde entier on la
retrouve sur internet
rt france point tv à bientôt
[Musique]